Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I want to talk about some of the
key moments in the third and final Maze Runner
movie, The Death Cure, as well as how they
affected its ending, and I'll also reveal
some interesting details, connections and
easter eggs you might have missed in the movie.
If this is your first time on my channel,
I do regular breakdowns of new movies, so
don't forget to hit the subscribe button and
notification bell to get my videos as soon
I post them, plus later in the video I'm also
announcing the winner of my latest giveaway.
Quick warning, I will be discussing spoilers
from Maze Runner: The Death Cure, so take
care if you've not seen the movie yet.
Let's start with the final scene and work
our way back to earlier moments which connect
to it.
Thomas wakes up from his injuries to find
himself in the Safe Haven with Minho and the
other surviving Immunes.
And there's an emotional moment for Thomas
when he finds a note inside the necklace that
Newt gave him.
In the letter, Newt tells his friend that
the thing that scares him most about the virus
is losing his memory to it.
Memory has been an important theme throughout
the Maze Runner films, with the first movie
showing the Gladers having no recollection
of their lives before entering the Maze, and
note how in this latest film, Teresa wants
to keep her memories of Thomas, despite Ava
Paige's offer to wipe them away, after all,
as Teresa says, 'if we find a cure that's
the only way all this was worth it.'
Ok, back to Newt's letter, he goes on to say
that if he could do everything all over again
he would and he wouldn't change a thing and
he hopes Thomas will feel the same years from
now.
Newt understands that Thomas has always been
the key to everyone's survival and he tells
him that "the future is in [Thomas's] hands
now" and that he'll have to find a way to
do what's right.
Soon after, when Thomas takes the vaccine
Teresa gave him out of his pocket, Newt's
words turn out to be literally true as Thomas
does indeed hold the secret to saving humanity
in his hands.
Another moment that showcases the trilogy's
key theme of memory is Vince's speech to the
survivors in the Safe Haven when he reveals
a large memorial stone to honour those who
didn't make it.
If you look carefully you'll spot the names
of characters who died during the series,
such as Zart from the first movie, but also
hidden in there are a few crew names like
Wes, a nod to Wes Ball, who directed all three
movies.
This moment also calls to mind the first Maze
Runner movie when the Gladers crossed out
a name on the maze wall whenever they lost
one of their group.
Thomas carves Teresa's name into the memorial
rock in honour of her sacrifice to save him
on top of the burning WCKD building.
Teresa's death was poignant not only because
of her feelings for Thomas, but also because
her sacrifice was in keeping with her ultimate
goal to find a vaccine for the Flare virus
for the whole of humanity, not just the select
few that Janson wanted to help.
Although she betrayed the Immunes at the end
of The Scorch Trials, it was only because
she believed in the idea that "WCKD [was]
good" and she always thought the Immunes'
sacrifice would ultimately save the human
race from devastation.
When Thomas asked her in The Death Cure if
she regretted what she'd done she simply replied
"Sometimes.
But I did what I thought was right [and] I'd
do it again", a sentiment which is later echoed
in Newt's letter to Thomas.
As Janson said to Teresa, "What I like about
you is no matter how bleak things get, you
never give up", and in the end, she was the
one who made the breakthrough as she understood
that Brenda's recovery after getting the serum
from Thomas in The Scorch Trials meant something
different was going on, which is why in this
film she smuggled out Thomas's bloody bandage
and inspected it in the lab.
Although she found it difficult to see her
friends suffer, in Teresa's mind it was ultimately
worthwhile for what she saw as the greater
good.
When she and Thomas are on the roof of the
WCKD building, she's aware they're both in
mortal danger and understands that Thomas
is the key to humanity's survival so she gives
him the serum of his blood that she was carrying
and ensures that he gets on the aircraft first.
With Teresa and Ava Paige dead at the end
of the Death Cure, and the Right Arm's scientist
Mary killed at the end of The Scorch Trials,
it's not entirely clear who will have the
expertise to replicate the vaccine, but I
guess that somewhere among the survivors there
may be another scientist who can help.
The other poignant death scene in The Death
Cure was, of course, when Thomas had to kill
Newt after the Flare infection finally turned
Newt into a Crank and he stabbed Thomas in
the chest.
There was plenty of foreshadowing for Newt's
eventual transformation into a Crank throughout
the movies.
For example, during Thomas's hallucination
scene in The Scorch Trials, he saw a vision
of Newt as a Crank.
And in The Death Cure, just before Thomas,
Newt and Frypan ventured into the tunnel,
Newt said "I don't want to come across as
too negative, but if I was a Crank, that's
exactly where I'd be".
Another thing foreshadowing Newt's death in
this film is a jar containing what appears
to be a dead newt which you can see briefly
in rebel leader Lawrence's room.
Brenda's line to Thomas in the movie, "you
can't save everyone", is also a bit of foreshadowing
for when Thomas stabs Newt, however, it has
a double-meaning because by the end of the
movie we know that Thomas can save everyone
as his blood is the basis for the ultimate
vaccine against the Flare virus.
There's also a nice parallel between Newt
giving his necklace to Thomas once he realises
he's unlikely to survive and Chuck who gave
Thomas his wooden carving as he died in the
first Maze Runner film.
And when Newt explained to Thomas that WCKD
must have put him into the maze "so they could
tell the difference between immunes like you
and people like me", it's a reference to Newt's
backstory in the books where Newt had a sister
who was an Immune abducted by WICKED.
In the books, WICKED decided to take Newt
with them as well to use him as a control
subject in their trials to see how Immunes
performed compared to ordinary people like
him.
One new character we meet in The Death Cure
is Lawrence, the rebel leader Gally's working
for outside the Last City.
When we meet him for the first time he has
a curious interest in roses, despite the loss
of his nose and much of his face to the Flare
virus.
This version of Lawrence is a clever reference
that book fans will recognise as he's partially
based on the "Rose took my nose" Crank that
Thomas encountered in The Scorch Trials book
but who never made it into the second Maze
Runner movie.
Now, did you enjoy The Death Cure film and
did you find the ending satisfying?
And if you've read the original books, how
do you think the movie series compares?
Feel free to share your thoughts in the comments
below.
If you enjoyed this, remember to hit that
thumbs-up button, share this video and also
subscribe to get more regular videos like
this.
The winner of my second Star Wars The Last
Jedi giveaway is on the screen right now.
If that's you, send me a private message with
your details to get your prize.
Check out more videos you might like by tapping
the screen right here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!